the girag an experience with these these
systems that are in place and the all
the various things that have gotten us
to 2019 as a human species when you
study anxiety and you study fear and all
these different things is are we
experiencing high levels of it because
there's not as much real physical danger
as our ancestors experienced and it's
almost like we're looking for it when
it's not necessarily there like we're
we're programmed to be able to deal with
it yeah that's a good point I hadn't
thought of it that way but I think
that's a good way to think about it I
mean you know the philosopher
Kierkegaard said that anxiety is the
price we pay for the human ability to
choose and this is where our utter
noetic consciousness comes in our
ability to think of ourselves as having
a past in the future and to be able to
plan and choose in the future you know
he said it started with Adam making the
first choice as a human in the Garden of
Eden and that was where it all began so
in our ability you know you can rephrase
that statement by saying our ability to
choose is what allows us to be anxious
because that is what anxiety is a worry
about what we have we're gonna make the
right decision you know how can we deal
with this thing that's coming up it's a
worry about the future and the ability
to think about the possibilities right
like what could go wrong would I go
right am i doing the right thing yeah
and then to contemplate all those
various choices right anxiety yeah so
like you know you're walking through the
woods as a snake you might freeze but
almost instantly that fear that is
generated by you freezing and seeing the
snake morphs into anxiety you know will
the snake bite me hmm if it bites me
will I get to a doctor will he have the
anecdote if I die what will happen to my
family you know that's word that sayings
on you so these are they're kind of
separate fear is about a danger that's
present
he's about one that hasn't happen yet
almost always as soon as you're afraid
that makes you anxious about what's
gonna happen and then there's general
existential angst mmm-hmm the just the
life itself existence is that just what
is it is what yeah and all of that is
due to our prefrontal cortex our ability
to conceptualize to you know imagine
things that have never been imagined
before to create art to build to create
architecture build buildings imagine
going to the moon designing an
instrument to do that and actually
pulling it off and make sure it can get
back all of that is something that our
special kind of consciousness enables
but it has a dark side which is it also
allows us to be incredibly selfish and
self-centered and narcissistic and to
support tribes and groups and you know
unless we I mean I think that the world
survives best when it's either
completely isolated all the cultures are
isolated or if we could also somehow be
together in a more unified way because
the direction we're going now where each
country is isolating itself but it still
so entangled with all the others is
recipe does it for disaster is this
because we evolved essentially without
long term travel I mean we kind of
evolved to stay in whatever area the
resources were in when we're hunters and
gatherers and then somewhere along the
line somebody figured out boats and how
to get on a horse and the next thing you
know you're visiting people I think it's
more about you know we have a special
kind of inquisitiveness that we can
because we can mentally model the next
step and plan what are the options you
know try to anticipate the the problems
that are going to come up
and take those steps and and that's a
pretty special thing but it also allows
us to plan in a kind of devious way
where you know me or my group is going
to benefit and if mine benefits I don't
want the other one to benefit because we
got to keep everything separate mmm so
it's you know consciousness our kind of
consciousnesses are you know greatest
achievement but also probably our worst
aspect
oof but it's all but it's what makes us
human
it's imagining humans with no
consciousness it's not possible it never
- there's no way to go in that direction
that's so is is the key to this thing as
the human race is it managing our
consciousness and perhaps maybe work
like yours giving us the tools to
understand what are the mechanisms
involved that maybe that can help us
sort of navigate our biological traps
and maybe